we'll change change course here with
Pete Hamill who joins us the national
college football basketball reporter for
Yahoo Sports what do you think of jaylen
hurts
I like jaylen hurts the best piece of
draft analysis I saw on Twitter on
gallons but had to be true was that a
lot of people haven't picked for
Baltimore so you can backup Lamar and
they can have a backup in their offense
you know you kind of Drew Bledsoe backup
Lamar Jackson right you need someone who
can of a similar skill set I'm not
necessarily comparing them because I
think Lamar in terms of quick twitch is
certainly in his own stratosphere
ultimately on Jalen I don't think he's
an NFL starter at the end of the day
like he will start NFL games but I don't
think he's a he's a guy a franchise well
takers first Paulie would you steal
Pete's comp and then we'll use that not
giving any credit absolutely that our
tradition okay all right yeah I stole it
too so we're passing it along here yeah
welcome to this business we don't give
credit yeah
all right a couple of things here I saw
where you were reporting that a couple
of sports have been canceled Cincinnati
with soccer
Old Dominion with wrestling and I know
that those don't garner headlines but
this is just the start it feels like of
the trickle-down that's a preemptive
strike to cancel these programs and we
haven't lost any income yet with these
college football programs so why now and
how bad do you think this is going to
get for the secondary sports based off
of maybe no college football for a
little while I think we're certainly set
up for what one source told me Dan I
thought was well but was a Twitter reset
the the collegiate athletics model is
completely upside-down when you look at
essentially one sport two sports at some
places you know providing I mean some
players have over 30 sports some tell me
you say there's a match school with 21 I
think UConn has 26 so when you have one
or two sports providing all of the money
for another you know at least 14 but in
some cases over 20 it's just not a
tenable long-term financial model and
I think financially athletic directors
always look at the bottom line I mean
Cincinnati once they pay off the
scholarships and in the remaining staff
is going to save eight hundred thousand
dollars a year so eight million dollars
over over a decade it's a lot of it's a
lot of money and certainly I don't want
to sound cold hearted when I'm talking
about this because I'm talking about
business decisions and these are lives
and you know people people just teams
are just ripped up and it's it's a it's
a difficult decision to make and one ad
who I called put it to put it to me this
way he said he's the old Winston
Churchill quote never waste a good
crisis so I don't think people woke up
and all of a sudden were like man maybe
we should cut sports I think people had
been looking at on their budgets for a
long time and this set of unique
financial circumstances that we're going
to come under because of coronavirus is
going to allow them to do what they
probably already already want even to
meet in in the best cases right like say
September 5th there's you know a hundred
thousand and the horseshoe for Bowling
Green and etc everywhere around the
country right now I don't see that as
particularly realistic but you know even
if that happens you're looking at donors
who are staring that at a twenty percent
dip in their portfolio you're looking at
you know people maybe don't want to go
back to sporting event you're looking at
at a minimum when I talk to a DS in the
best case scenarios they're looking at
maybe an AAMCO count for a for a 20%
deposit so you need places to save money
and if there is no football I mean
that's what all but that's when all bets
are off I'm also wondering about how
this helps the economy if we do have
sporting events but we don't have fans
going to the sporting events well my
thought on college is that you have to
look at it different than the than the
NFL NBA and NHL I very confident I wrote
this two to three weeks ago if there is
no college there will be no college
sports and I had a lot of you know Bob
Bowles be told me that you know people
of people you know athletic records on
the country have kind of said that so no
is no note no sports okay can't bring
students back to campus you can't have a
football team go play unless you stop
calling them student-athletes and you
just call them athletes athletics
student yes that would be and that would
just be a whole thing so I don't know
how college football could thread the
needle of well it's safe for students to
come to campus it's C for athletes to
come to campus but it's not safe to have
visitors in a stadium that I think the
percentage chance for college football
with no fans is very low I'm not saying
it's impossible but I think it's much
more realistic you know you have NBA
games in Vegas or in a cruise ship or
whatever they're talking about or even
the NFL Dan Watson wrote this two weeks
ago would be the hardest one to do all
this because you've got a you know you
can you can throw the NBA in the NHL on
a metaphorical Dakotah it's hard to do
that with the NFL it's just such a big
looming operation to move 32 teams to
one play it would just be a logistical
nightmare so but for for college
football I'd be stunned if we had if we
had games without fans you take a look
at the the Florida's the Ohio State's
you know your your your big big programs
you're doing about 50 million dollars in
ticket revenue alone so it's it's it's a
huge and certainly the TV revenue is is
as much for those you know for the Big
Ten's in the SE C's it's in that it's in
that forty million dollar neighborhood
but I I have a hard time imagining that
from a liability standpoint you know
you're gonna have that the complicated
part of college too and we're seeing
this with governor Newsom and maybe his
projections not being as optimistic as
president Trump's projections in college
like there's municipalities there's
mayor's there's college presidents like
I mean if there's one thing about
college athletics its it's from a
leadership perspective it's very fraught
you know in its it's very it's very
different yeah that's the problem
there's I talked to Chris Fowler
yesterday you said there's no singular
voice here like you commissioners in
other sports I'll leave you with this I
talked to Fowler about this that you
have four teams in the in the playoffs
can you extend
and make it 16 can you can you break
that contract to make it 16 therefore we
have more revenue and then maybe by the
end of the year we can have football
where we have fans in the stands or III
don't know if that chris said
everything's on the table do you think
we could get to 16 playoff teams well I
wrote this week that I think the playoff
will change to accommodate finances you
know in this crisis like in terms of in
terms of new revenue streams that's one
of the few certain ones that they could
make in calling around it to people tied
to the college football playoff the
notion of changing it this year was like
way off the table they were like it even
next year just because of the different
Bulls it's tied to two different
logistics now look we're you know
they're going to be the you know all all
sports officials are going to be the
goalie standing on their head right
trying to figure out how to get sports
and in my on the plane here but I I
would be pretty surprised if they could
just rip up a billion dollar contract I
mean they're six years left on that 12
year deal and when you really dive into
it there's just hot of in it looked as
you see n of the money right now to just
rip up the six most profitable years on
a contract to do it to expand the thing
I don't think that's that's a no-brainer
either like it would be in better times
so I do think the playoff does expand I
I think the earliest we could see it Dan
is two years from now and I'd imagine we
go to eight from there be good to talk
to you we appreciate you joining us as
always Dan thanks for time that's a Pete
famil national college football
basketball reporter for Yahoo Sports